so wait you and Nick have a ritual that
I didn't know about so it's called show
and tell this is pretty cute it kind of
was in a ritual it just happened because
of necessity
um we both didn't know very much about
each other's careers I mean I know of
the Jonas Brothers but you know it's a
different generation yeah I was like I
didn't really grow up with the music and
yes I didn't know the history even
though him and I both have 22-year
careers because he started his at seven
yeah
um but so we started showing each other
each other's work like we would sit and
be like oh you know this was the most
traumatic day on set for me on my first
movie and he was like oh this was my
most traumatic show and we'd kind of
show each other uh careers or highlights
from our careers and talk about what we
were really feeling that time and it's
just become this thing that we do
whenever we're by ourselves at home yeah
go down the rabbit hole cause y'all met
and y'all got together pretty quickly
right yeah so it's kind of cool you get
to know each other like still yeah I
mean we knew each other for about two
years yeah but we didn't like really
date we were both in other things
like doing like other jobs and stuff
yeah no other relationships
[Laughter]
for sure
awesome though like to show like I don't
know I just think it's a very cute way
to like get to know your significant
other that you think you know everything
about but they weren't there for that
whole they weren't yeah and I think it's
such a fun thing to especially both of
us have had such public careers we've
both grown up in our own way I love that
you both didn't know each other's
careers I know it's so crazy that's kind
of cool I think so too yeah it's really
fun like you know you're there for the
right reason we show each other our
embarrassing moments because you know
that's your person and you're safe with
them yeah and it's funny you have bad
performances and be able to laugh at it
yeah oh me too
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]